the president is also under growing
pressure from congress to respond to
allegations russia paid
bounties to kill u.s troops in
afghanistan the white house now confirms
mr trump has been briefed but insists
that u.s
intelligence agencies disagree on
whether the claims are accurate
ben tracy reports on white house anger
that the classified information became
public in the first place
this damages our ability as a nation to
collect intelligence
white house press secretary kelley
mcenany railed against what she called
targeted leaks but did not deny there is
intelligence
indicating the russians offered bounties
to attack u.s
troops sources tell cbs news that
information was not
verbally told to president trump but
that it was in his classified daily
brief
the white house disputed reports that he
doesn't read it
the president does read and he also
consumes intelligence
verbally this president i'll tell you is
the most informed person on planet earth
when it comes to the threats that we
face
but for days the white house has claimed
the president was completely unaware of
the russia allegations
because u.s intelligence agencies had
not reached a consensus
on tuesday former vice president joe
biden said there's no excuse for
president trump
not knowing the presidential grief is
something i read
every single day as vice president the
president read it every day
the idea that somehow he didn't know
or isn't being briefed it is a
dereliction of duty
president trump's former national
security adviser john bolton
who is promoting his scathing new book
about the president
says he understands why president trump
may have been uninformed
president doesn't much like being
briefed he thinks he knows what he needs
needs to know democrats briefed by the
white house
questioned why the president has not
promised to get to the bottom of the
allegations
the president called this a hoax
publicly nothing in the briefing that we
have just received
led me to believe it is a hoax
republicans also want to hear more
any targeting of u.s forces by russians
by anyone else will face a very swift
and deadly response
now the president has just weighed in on
these russia allegations again in a
tweet he says the russia bounty story is
just another made up by fake news tale
that is told only to damage me and the
republican party
anthony ben thank you very much